hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about thromboxane
so what comes in your mind when you hear
the term thromboxane
thrombosis right or blood clotting
and this is correct because thromboxane
is named so because of its role in clot
formation
thromboxane is a member of the family of
derived lipids
which are actually ecosynod
derivatives so that means they are
derived
from the arachidonic acid so acetonic
acid can get converted to thromboxane a2
or thromboxin b2 and the key enzyme that
is helping in this process
is known as thromboxane asymptotes
both the thromboxane types are
characterized
by their six membered ether containing
cyclic
rings this is a characteristic chemical
feature
of thromboxanes now let's talk about how
thromboxane is synthesized inside the
cell so thromboxane is synthesized in
the platelets
on the platelet membrane there would be
phospholipase and this would generate
arachidonic acid now arachitonic acid
would be converted initially
to prostaglandin h2 with the help of
cyclooxygenase
later on prostaglandin h2 can be
converted to either
prostacyclin or it can be converted to
thromboxin
a2 with the help of thromboxane
asymptotes
so prostaglandin h2 formation is a team
node step
now let me remind you that thromboxane
a synthesis enzyme is exclusively
present
in the platelet membrane so obviously
platelet is the
site for thromboxine production
thromboxane
once generated can bind to thromboxane
receptors
present in wide variety of cell for
example blood vessels
and thromboxane ultimately leads to
g protein mediated signaling
which elevates calcium level in the
cytoplasm
now once calcium level is elevated it
helps in clot formation
or eventually in vasoconstriction so one
of the major function of thromboxane
is to perform vasoconstriction now let
me remind you at this point
that thromboxin and prostacycline has
opposite role
prostacycline has a vasodilatory role
whereas
thromboxane has vasoconstriction
role now it is believed
that vasoconstriction caused by
thromboxane could be the underlying
cause
of prince metals and genome or
any kind of cardiac inflammatory disease
one of the
leading role could be played by
thromboxanes
now let me tell you that in your diet if
you have sufficient amount of omega-3
fatty acids
then the thromboxin that is generated
would be
different so if you have too much of
omega-3 fatty acids
then thromboxane a3 is generated instead
of
a2 while a2 is a potent vasoconstrictor
a3 is less potent and that is why the
vasoconstriction mediated aberrant
effects are less
if your diet contains omega-3 fatty acid
if you want to know more about omega-3
fatty acids
and its health benefit click on the link
in the eye button
now let me tell you vessel constriction
effect of thromboxine could be a
feature of many diseases such as
cardiac diseases like ischemia
reperfusion
disease and also hepatic inflammation
and acute hepatotoxicity
underlying all these disease it is
believed that thromboxane is playing a
key role in this pathophysiology
now thromboxane inhibitors are really
important to treat these kind of
diseases
and you can understand at a molecular
level where thromboxane inhibitors could
potentially work
first of all it can work at
cyclooxygenase level
so by blocking cyclooxygenase specific
uh substances such as aspirin
can block the production of thromboxane
other than that thromboxane selective
synthesis inhibitor can also inhibit
thromboxane a synthesis the red limiting
step of thromboxane
biosynthesis process and there could be
other inhibitors which are
antagonist of thromboxane receptor which
prevents from boxing a2 to bind to their
receptor and thereby prevent from
unboxing signaling
so these are few ways by which
thromboxane can be controlled or the
effect of thromboxane could be
moderated so i hope this video was
informative enough if you like this
video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
you can support me on patreon
and if you want to access my core uh
course in an academy
you can use my code mp10 to get a 10
discount and do let me know in the
comment how you like my video because
your comment give me so much of
motivation so that i can make more
videos thank you
see you in the next video